hi everyone it's Jerry let's have a look
at a game that was played at the ongoing
2023 fiday World rapid
championship this was a round five game
between Magnus Carlson on the white end
and chimur gev time controls are 15+ 10
going into this round five game Carlson
had three and a half points his opponent
was the only player on four out of four
now what we're going to observe with
this game is how we can handle an
opponent who plays aggressively with the
pawns at an early
stage and we see this by move six comes
out of R Lopez steinet
variation castles prep work for the
central expansion and here we go
G5 now if this game was played online
you may be thinking to yourself as white
did Black just Mouse slip did Black
really intend
G6 G6 is a perfectly reasonable move
much more solid
approach G5 on the other hand is the
most committal move you can make four
holes have just been
created what would be your response here
is white feel free to pause the
video
okay I'd like to share some words about
this position that I think may be
helpful for your own
game your knight on F3 is going to be
kicked G4 is going to happen you're just
going to have to deal with it and find a
new home for that
night trying to secure its post on F3
with H3 is a faulty train of thought
because you would only be inviting H5
and G4 would still hit your knight would
still have to find a new home and in the
process a file will will be cracked open
towards your own King very easy for
white to find himself in hot water and
in a completely losing
position
therefore we don't move this
Pawn Carlson is not distracted by G5
very easy in general in this game to be
distracted by your opponent's last move
on move six Carlson said a move seven
he's justifying it the knight's kicked
back to rank one where it stays out of
the way of the queen side miners black
continues to push
pawns Where Do We Go From Here well it's
still the opening we still need to focus
on fundamentals even though there is
this caveman likee approach by
black we need to develop the pieces
these weaknesses on the kingside do know
they're not going away they're static
weaknesses they're there forever there's
a big question mark over the black king
black has been successful demoting this
Knight there's a big question mark over
this guy where you going you going to go
King side where there's all these
weaknesses or you going to hang a left
where this guy right here on A6 can
maybe provide white a nice hook to pry
openen the B
file okay let's get some development in
Queens and dark Square Bishops
playing there's some pressure mounting
on
D4 it's released tension is released and
we follow up with Knight D3 that's its
new home and notice it's immediately
eyeing up the weakness behind Black's
last move after d takes E5 C5 is a bit
soft Knights are connected Knight
D2 Knight G6 this is a scary piece
should we stop stop it from getting to
F4 with
G3 no Carlson still keeps these guys on
home base close to the
king in this game it's Knight C5 if you
play
G3 you're asking again for a file to be
ripped
open in this one it's Knight
C5 black plays Bishop C8 here the
suggestion by the engine is to Castle
Queen side and be okay with this
exchange black wants to preserve the
bishop this Knight dominates not just
the bishop but the Rook how I frequently
like to view it is three points are
controlling
eight what's this guy going to do if
this guy can't
move Carlson's Queen Rook can definitely
contribute does on this move 15
only open file now
occupied Knight F4 this is the
Intolerable piece it's got to go Bishop
takes Knight in the game it's Bishop
takes
Bishop if you recapture with the pawn
this guy bolts a square opens up for the
second ranked Knight and Knight F6 is
going to hit so Bishop takes
Bishop Bishop is challenged pressure on
this Pawn as
well now it's kingside
castles is now the time we can think a
bit more about advancing pawns on our
King
side yes especially with this Rook no
longer on the H
file Carlson takes some steps with the
pawns only at this stage only after
black has made the commitment to go to
the king side it's not some race
position it's it's not an opposite sides
castles position same sides castles
ahead
G3 with the followup F4 will pry openen
the f
file white will be granted access to in
other words F5 and F6 with the
Rook F3 was another
move in the engine's eyes but in this
one it is
F4 this is where black goes seriously
wrong the suggestion by the engine is to
take on F4 and play with this
structure Dynamic game still ahead I'm
not exactly sure how the pawns will be
positioned this still has um some nice
appeal to it E5 with Knight to E4 in
this game though it is G takes on F on
ban the second rank Knight is improved
it is on its way to occupy one of the
big
weaknesses in Black's Camp ever since
move six G5
F5 has been a desirable Square for a
piece white now has a path into that
square Bishop is developed there's a pin
white has to sort
out easy enough Queen is out of the way
Queen also preps H3 black has an eye on
that Queen is immediately challenged she
goes back and now the bishop driven back
and now we're moving forward a lot of
forward moves for White and the reply by
black is to
retreat Knight clearly looking to hop in
to F5 a check is thrown in I must admit
these remaining moves
by black it kind of feels like black is
a fish out of water just kind of
flipping and flopping about whether the
bishop is on this
diagonal or this
diagonal uh not really doing anything
it's not connected with any other black
piece
it's easily worked
around King
H2 Queen G5 Knight F5 pressure on the
bishop black tries to work around this
piece in the game it's Bishop B6 if you
take the Knight a rook on F5 is also a
very good piece not easily
extracted in this one though it's Bishop
B6 Queen's kicked back Queen E2 eyeing
up another one of those weaknesses on
the king side Queen Corner po pocket a
sad move and now G4 right around the
corner possible opening up of the G file
even if it costs the exchange this is an
overwhelming attack for
white black tries to get off of the G
file in time with King H7 and King
h8 but in the process not white has this
space has a fifth ranked Knight and they
coordinate perfect
perfect Knight H6 cuts the queen from
her defense of H5 and there's no
defending
it Queen G6 simply runs into Rook
F6 taking advantage of yet another one
of those weaknesses every one of these
squares every one of these four
weaknesses that were created on move six
are now being pounced on some 20 25
moves
later in this game we continue with
Bishop takes Bishop I should note clock
times to give you an idea here after
this move black really only had seconds
a handful of seconds to work with and
Carlson still had 12
minutes we
recapture
F6 Queen takes Pawn what else is there
Bishop E3 the threat after Queen takes
on H5 is to play G6 kick the queen away
so for instance if the Rook played here
there's
G6 Queen here we're going to win the
queen with the discovered
check Queen somewhere else it's going to
lead to
mate Queen H7
upcoming Bishop E3 how are things
different G6 here there's Queen takes
Knight but the bishop on E3 is not
stable it's challenged right
away and we're going to have the win of
a piece soon enough what other options
are are there besides this
capture um Bishop here it's challenged
right away Bishop F4 we take and then
again there's this G6 idea so there's no
good move there has hasn't been a good
move for black for sometime what's tried
is f takes
G we first exchange Rooks and simply win
the free piece it's in this position
black
resigns so what' you think of this one
anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below I hope you enjoyed it and
maybe took a thing or two away that's
all for now take care
bye